j'en lis pérenne bonjour merci d'être
heures en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors si le projet de la direction de
sanofi va à son terme quelles pourraient
être les conséquences pour les salariés
de sanofi sur le sol européen l'a
écoutée si l'écossé et galles c'était
pour nos commerciaux ce sera 9 5 9 5 24
suppressions de postes supplémentaires
donc qui s'ajoutent aux plus de 9 500
faits ou 900 suppressions de postes dans
la recherche a coûté ccm termes d'emploi
sanofi s'est lassé la fuite en avant
c'est la fuite en avant et on a vraiment
une politique aux réalités vert vers le
profit si je crois depuis 2008 les
effectifs de sanofi en france c'était
par m2 de 26 me de 5105 cdi en activité
aujourd'hui de faire un 2020 les
effectifs étaient de 21000 e45 donc
quasiment six mille 6000 poste à moins
depuis 2008 et la chute
la chute continue par hamas a pas l'air
de déranger nous nous dirigeâmes
politiques qui laissent faire
sanofi et ça a pas l'air de les deux de
faire en sorte de ne pas de pas verser
sa note y décrit des dames fois que ce
soit les fidèles poireau cher et
finissent d'études il a décrit des
recherches ou sixième fois donc cli
d'impôts voilà tout ça est fait avec
l'accord l'accord du gouvernement et
c'est honteux surtout de cette période
pandémique
comment expliquez vous justement cette
stratégie de sanofi le groupe
pharmaceutique
une seule explication c'est que sanofi
mise tout sur le profit et pour faire
ces profils bas sanofi fait fait des
faits des économies afin de faire de
l'innovation et c'est une économie
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui nous prive nous
prive de l'innovation interne essais et
seguer malheureux mais sanofi depuis
8c'est des plans d'économies sur panne
économique tous les deux à trois heures
on a deux milliards d'économies à faire
d'un second on demande un effort de 2
milliard d'économies aux salariés vous
comprenez bien que cela ne peut pas
durer
dont elle plus que on me marre nous
amenons cd des investissements massifs
dans les vaccins source sur scène gapeau
hauteur de 4,5 bino donc on voit bien
que sanofi est en train de se désengager
petit à petit de la vieille europe et là
on parle de l'externalisation de de nos
forces tu fonction de notre force
commerciale
mais sanofi s'apprête aussi à rester
organisés des capacités de production de
principes actifs et de médicaments avec
la création d'une nouvelle entité qui ne
fera plus partie du groupe sanofi d'un
zona la création de la société euro api
de laquelle sanofi va y est précédée
dernière question c'est le projet est
mené à son terme qu'est ce que vous
exigez de sanofi qu'elle pourrait être
voilà les mesures d'accompagnement à ses
salariés concernés mais je crois que je
fais je crois qu'il faut arrêter avec
eux avec cette idée que on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas empêcher on ne peut pas
éviter cette stratégie destructrice d'un
destructrices d'emploi et nous on veut
même pas imaginer que sanofi va pouvoir
aller à son terme
rien que le fait de l'imaginer de et de
l'accompagner ça a permis à sanofi de
réduire ses effectifs ne serait ce qu'en
france 2 depuis deux ans et demi le celi
de qu' il faut arrêter d'être dans cette
cette situation où on accompagne les
plaies les politiques disent riche et
destructrice au prado d'emplois est
aujourd'hui faut passer nous on invite
les salariés à passer à l'offensive et a
refusé tout c'est tout c'est stratégique
et au final être orientés simplement une
chose sur le profit alors oui il ya des
communiqués de presse ils sont parus
indien que la moindre des choses serait
de pérenniser l'activité de ses salariés
qui vont qui vous me passez qui vont
passer des entreprises externes
miser leurs activités sur 5 anne laure
l'ont rassuré la même rémunération mais
au final c'est des pansements sur une
jambe de bois
aujourd'hui il faut s'attaquer au mal et
le mal aujourd'hui c'est cesser les
profits que sanofi veut faire 5 5 très
capable d'innover et c'est aujourd'hui
le problème est là et le mal est là il
faut attaque s'attaquer à ce mal et pour
cela on a aussi besoin des pouvoirs
publics
il va falloir qu'à un moment donné les
pouvoirs publics prennent près prennent
le sujet au sérieux parce que mine de
rien petit à petit sanofi est en train
de de tuer l'industrie pharmaceutique en
france et en europe
et je crois que les chèques sur de la
recherche sur un vaccin contre la copie
ou du moins le retard à l'allumage que
des fans autres notre président est
monsieur bobillot je crois que tout se
sait tech etc là ils seront tard là la
preuve en est un on est en train de
payer la politique du groupe en fait
depuis depuis depuis plus de maintenant
12,1 quoi il faut que ça s'arrête et on
ne peut plus cautionner on ne peut pas
imaginer que ce nouveau plug destructif
je me vois arriver
merci beaucoup en tout cas jean louis
perrin d'avoir réagi sur rtl france je
rappelle que vous êtes coordinateur cgt
sanofi